foreign
Ed using your previously ing on and on
to insinuate that the band Creed could
redeem anyone also using 90 90 seconds
to show me scenes and helmets I've
already seen before also also why does
the armorer get their shoulder fluff in
the shot no one else gets shoulder fluff
two pod racers are terrible drivers why
are they wasting so much time swerving
around when they should be focused on
tight turns and extended Burns also you
can clearly hear a large crowd cheering
in the background so where are they is
that noise piped in from somewhere what
is this the NFL consecutive also also's
is this a desert Town wait is that most
Eisley oh no no no no no no no no they
tricked me Disney snuck a book of Boba
Fett episode into my Mandalorian didn't
they bastards
we never heard a price exchanged between
these two and he's just giving her a
random bag of what we assume her credits
which may or may not be any good
depending on whether or not the mechanic
operates under the watto bartering
system my point is anything could be in
this pouch and we have zero idea how
much should be in there
if all the Droid was going to do to
alert the jaw was was whistle why don't
you just do that yourself quickly before
he sees you you say this literally six
seconds after saying until the job was
Roadie and left tell them he's gone tell
them he could see them that's just
terrible workplace communication put
those parts back on the speeder painters
they look different this is a simple
enough scam so why do you even need the
Jawas as the middlemen or middle Jawas
and isn't selling people their own back
at Jawa trademark at this point both
parties are splitting a job either one
of them could do themselves just so the
audience can get their Jawa fixed before
Mando shows up hurry like a nuzzle shrew
seeing does not contain a nuzzle shrew
it's a good thing grogu spent two years
training with Luke so he could learn how
to jump and do a flip
[Music]
thanks a lot pelie now I'm aware that
they're eventually going to ruin grogu
by making him talk preemptive sin this
is get right back here right back there
scary Droid not understanding the
strengths and weaknesses of your
Workforce pelly needs some Management
training like immediately
[Music]
and what I'm gonna do is
price and throwing a free oil bath
offering Mando a free oil bath without
inviting us to wait she was talking
about the Droid wasn't she I thought you
said it was built for adventure I'm torn
on the one hand I'm glad we're skipping
the fix the Droid side quest before we
get to Mandalore but on the other hand
Dennis spent two seasons making a huge
stink about not trusting droids he
finally builds trust with ig-11 and now
he's just open to relying on random
astromechs that seems out of character
and since I can't decide which way I'm
leaning go ahead and take us in for each
just to be safe
how does pelly know what the force is
she's not a Jedi or part of the
Rebellion this show went to Such Great
Lengths to show the Jedi Were Somehow
forgotten after The Purge Mando even
called them Sorcerers remember so which
is it do people remember the Jedi or not
it's Mandalore the Homeworld of our
people
every Mandalorian can trace their Roots
back to this planet apparently grogo is
quickly just becoming a landing vessel
for din to tell us all the Mandalore
maybe instead of baby Yoda we should
have called him an expositional sponge
Yoda trips right off the tongue huh I've
never been there either them how do you
know what you're speaking one's green
and beautiful and that's kalavala where
we visited Boca town I'm only telling
you this in case there's some sort of
rare emergency where I'm incapacitated
in you need to run to her for help no
other reason a Mandalorian has to
understand maps and know their way
around pretending that using graphic
instructions on how to get from point A
to point B is a unique skill set looks
like the fusion bombs from The Purge it
disrupted the magnetic field around the
planet
from the surface we won't be able to
communicate with anyone out of
atmosphere meteorological plot obstacles
meteoroplaticals go over to that split
in the Rock and take an air sample of
the ruins below wait with the air below
the Rocks not be the same as the air
above if the Droid can just pop down in
there does your ship not have sensors to
indicate if the atmosphere is breathable
this whole Droid companion thing makes
more sense when you needed someone to
watch your back but taking a Droid for
air samples seems a bit like Overkill
[Music]
don't be a baby what a weird insult for
a Droid droids like much technology are
likely at their highest level of
operation and strength when they're
first created I know you hate droids
Mando but the cultural insensitivity is
just off the charts you can watch them
on the scope it's a red dot on an
unmarked circular grid and honestly what
other information would you ever need I
was hoping to avoid going out there but
you'd have to go out there eventually
right you can't bathe in the Living
Waters from your cockpit Mando don't
worry kid I'll be right back Pedro says
they're sitting so much in the shows
he's currently in he should probably
just trademark this line and make some
residuals on it being blessed with great
equipment but not knowing how to use it
the charts were wrong what charts so far
this is the only chart I've been shown
and if I'm being really honest
discussions on charts are about one
notch above discussions about fuel
levels taking your tiny companion into a
dangerous unknown Planet dressed as half
of an avocado grogu copying what Mando
does through this cave walk just a few
seconds after he does it is just one
more example of how completely the show
understands the parent-child dynamic and
it's threatening to melt my best car
encased heart damn it
wait wait wait wait I know Disney owns
pretty much everything but does that
include the rights to Metal Gear Konami
really did go to shoot after Kojima left
if they sold off the franchise rights
for a Star Wars crossover also you're
telling me that whole mech suit was
underneath the sand upside down waiting
to pounce how long would it take to set
that up how could it possibly be worth
it in this environment man bet you wish
you had Yoda's lightsaber right about
now huh how's that little best car vest
treating you
if they could bring back malls several
times then General grievius was always
within the realm of possibility his new
suit sure is a downgrade though no he's
going to be windmilling lightsabers in
that thing if you're just a tiny blob of
biological material around a single
eyeball how did you make all this stuff
in the first place where did you get the
pieces did you pickle Rickett and
magically build an operational
exoskeleton by tonguing a Mandalorian
cockroach brain
and this instruction should be enough
for you thanks to the convenient map
teaching I did on the way here and don't
forget you'll have to fly all the way
there because of the damn meteoro
ploticle that's already in place I will
say this whole section where grogu
becomes a playable character and goes on
his own side quest is all of the awesome
and grogu somehow continues to force
pull sins out of me
wait a minute you can use the force to
smoke this guy but not the robot what
exactly did you learn during your two
years of training with Luke Skywalker an
unscheduled visitor pronouncing SCH as
sh did you not pay attention in shul or
are you too busy sheaming shematics to
steal a scholarship I'm done schmoozing
this schmaltzy schlock vest wait those
worked fine now I'm sitting here shot in
freuda damn it maybe I didn't make
myself clear the last time
I want to be left alone you actually
didn't make that clear last time at no
point did you tell Mando and grogu to
leave you alone so you could listen to
whatever the Mandalorian version of My
Chemical Romance is and sulk like a
teenager who ran out of their favorite
eyeliner looking down on the apocalyptic
remains of the city really as impressive
how this episode is just the Last of Us
episode 8 Pedro Pascal is trying to
teach a child with a special ability how
to navigate and make it in an
apocalyptic Wasteland when he's taken
out of commission and the child has to
formulate a way to get help and since
that episode came out three whole days
before this one I have to send this
episode for being such a copycat them's
just the rules taking off your helmet in
a dangerous place because it's time to
speechify purposely Landing in a puddle
when there's dry ground a foot away
needing a reminder from a child that
flashlights are a good idea in a cave I
knew quite a few Jedi you know using the
some of my best friends are Jedi defense
pushing your vulnerable companion into a
dark corner you haven't explored because
you spotted something dangerous in the
other direction as if danger can't
simultaneously be located in multiple
places did you think your dad was the
only Mandalorian no grogu met Boba Fett
and your followers in season two
remember so obviously he knows din isn't
the only Mandalorian and obviously you
know he knows and obviously I know you
know he knows
night saber location is convenient but
also watching Boca tan slay with this
thing is honestly worth any of their
random convenience it took to get here
because this is bad freaking ass how did
you find me your last words to grogu
were literally
you've never eaten pong soup
no can you appreciate the irony I cannot
also cut the man some slack he didn't
live through the 90s when those were
briefly a thing and even I didn't know
you could make soup out of him thank you
that would thank me until you see them
trying to control someone else's
thankfulness what pains me of seeing our
own kind fight one another time and time
again funny you didn't seem that upset
about the Civil War during Clone Wars
having this in your possession and just
now using it hold on I want you to get
the full tour people who read the
expositional signs instead of just
enjoying the thing that the sign is
about the grand Canyon's right there
Zeke not currently interested in the
story of Gary The Gorge donkey in his
three-month journey I swear on my name I
teased in for keeping up the silly
religious Creed stuff but at least he
doesn't use his faith as an excuse to be
a dick to people different than him so
here's a sin for those that do what do
you call a Mandalorian that has to be
rescued twice in one episode a Denzel in
distress
hahaha
almost done cool shot but should the no
longer mythosaur be doing more than just
watching this rescue does the water ball
Rock get his kicks from just watching
rescues as they happen I guess what I'm
saying is Miffy how's the beeping how's
the beeping
I don't think they exist The Lion King
where'd he useful lunking I'm spelunking
for pork rinds
that thing got a hammy
don't be a baby who are you who are you
calling baby be right back
don't worry kid see you pushed the laws
and you end up dead
they have a cave troll what's wrong
snake snake there the entrance to the
mines of mandalor this is my friend is
the home of my cousin's volleyball and
they call it a mine
a mine
this is no mine
it's a tomb